later on charges of terrorism and it's a
first
is that correct yes we're using
terrorism which gives us extra strength
in New York and Nevada 21 ms-13 members
and leaders have been indicted on
charges including murder kidnapping and
drug trafficking the DOJ has also
announced that it will seek the death
penalty for a bloodthirsty ms-13 leader
you
here's gonna be one of the strongest
years economically we've ever had so I'm
going to ask AG barn and say a few words
about the ms-13 and what we've done and
what we're doing and where we plan to go
and next week we're going to have I
think a very exciting news conference
because we're going to be talking about
some of these cities that were the
Democrats running them have just lost
control of the city so that'll be very
interesting bill please when I came into
the department his Attorney General the
president made it clear that one of his
top priorities to reduce violent crime
in the United States was to destroy
ms-13 in the United States and what
we've been in here discussing with the
president is part of that effort which
is a project
Volken or task force vulcan which is
targeting the higher level players in
the ms-13 operations in the United
States ms-13 is somewhat unique in this
sense they have the street savagery that
you would see and it can a gang is not
driven by commercial interests the way
for example the Mafia traditionally was
it's about honor of being the most
savage bloodthirsty person you can be
and building up a reputation as a killer
so this is in some ways as a death cult
and then they use the terror that they
caused by their savagery to extort and
they've gotten increasingly into human
trafficking and now narcotics
trafficking but that's a sidelight to
some extent to their basic purpose which
is violence and terrorizing people also
unlike a street gang they're highly
organized as a transnational
organization they operate with hierarchy
with programs they call them programs
think of it as a crime family
essentially and then under each program
they have different cliques they have
programs and cliques operating in the
United States well their center of
gravity is in Central America there are
thousands that have come into the United
States illegally they're virtually all
illegal aliens they come in now although
it's harder to get across the border but
traditionally they've
across the border into Houston and then
fanned out across the United States and
the different centers of activity today
we were talking with the president about
three actions where he took Melgar Diaz
was indicted in the Eastern District of
Virginia first time we've used terrorism
charges against a member of ms-13 he was
responsible for activities in 13 states
20 clicks in the United States he was
also the person who would greenlight
assassinations in the United States the
orders come from El Salvador the
requests to assassinate people go down
to El Salvador he would greenlight the
hit you also took down this was a HSI
case in Las Vegas we took down the
Hollywood clique which operated not only
in Nevada but also in California and in
Eastern District New York again Long
Island and we took down 21 members and
the leadership of that organization
and then finally these are the New York
inductees and then finally I announced
that we are going to seek the death
penalty against Alexei sayans who is a
leader in in the Eastern District of New
York a leader of ms-13 there the
president made a trip to Brentwood New
York earlier in his administration and
he met with the families of victims that
had been killed by NS 13 including the
family of two young girls who were
butchered with machetes and the person
that we are seeking the death penalty
against was involved in those murders as
well as the murder of two African
Americans who they they just saw on the
street and thought they were from a
rival gang and just butchered so those
are the actions were taken there's more
coming as we can target the leadership
of ms-13 we're working very closely with
the El
Orient's on this they've been very
cooperative and we have MS we have the
HSI and the FBI with operations down in
El Salvador in past administrations El
Salvador Honduras Guatemala did not
cooperate with the United States at all
they wouldn't let us bring people back
and under this administration a long
time ago almost my I would say my second
or third day is that's not going to work
they bring them back in this they get
him out of here we're not taking them
and they don't say that anymore they
don't even come close to saying that
anymore so the the operation is going to
be very good this is probably the
meanest worst gang anywhere in the world
the ms-13 group and big dentist put in
them it took place over the last few
days and and really over the last year
heavy focus on ms-13 they're an evil
group of people they're sick and
deranged and we're taking care of it and
I want to just thank these great crime
fighters that are with us today
Eastern District of Virginia Zak
Terwilliger obviously you know the
director of the FBI that ends of the ice
Mike carvahal of Bureau of Prisons
you might ask the Bureau of Y the Bureau
of Prisons because they do like to try
to operate out of prisons and we have to
make sure we collect intelligence in a
prison system and then Regina Lombardo
of ATF Tim Shea of DEA of course you
know the Secretary of DHS like central
casting we forgot what was the head of
this program is John Durham Jr who has
spent 13 years ten years on Long Island
which is one of the hot beds that's
really good it was so important
it's like central casting people are
like central
casting and you're going to do a great
job and we appreciate it and we will be
meeting you in a similar vein but a
little different subject next week and
that concerns our cities and again
people that have lost control of some of
our great cities will get and straighten
things out
thank you all very much thank you you'll
be seeing next week we'll have a
conference next week and we'll tell you
in great detail but it's something that
I think at this point the American
people want to see they've been run very
poorly these cities whether it's Seattle
where we were getting ready to go in and
they decided to go in and that's good
Minneapolis where we had the National
Guard go in and as soon as they did that
we straighten that mess out they should
have been able to do it locally with
their police tell police are good they
were told not to do anything or many
other cases we're doing a great job in
Portland Portland was very rough and
they called us in and we did a good job
to put it mildly many people in jail
right now but we have other cities that
are out of control they're like war
zones and if the city isn't gonna
straighten and out of local politicians
all in this case I'll say this for
political reasons they're all Democrats
they're liberal left-wing Democrats and
it's almost like they think this is
going to be this way forever we're in
Chicago sixty-eight people were shot and
18 died last week we're not going to put
up with it we're not going to put up
with it so that's for our next
discussion thank you all very much well
let's have a very good
you